i'm dying for some fresh air
once again i'm masahiro sakurai yeah oh
you
did it
okay all right welcome back to another
episode of the worst way to play
cyberpunk 2077
the show where we push it to the limit
and try to play the game in the worst
possible way that's on a base
xbox one with no updates this is version
1.1
as you can see here what are we looking
at there's no idea
you're going to see some stutters you're
going to see some crashes and we're
going to try to power through and finish
this game
um before we get going don't forget to
give us a like or subscribe
uh if you want to see more of this show
or more content like it
it really helps us out jake what are we
doing today
aside from dealing with the burden of
this version
i think we do some story missions i
think i think that's the play
let's get out of first person as soon as
po actually stupid of
first person driving okay i haven't done
much of this
i'm i'm game oh
that's why i don't do first-person
driving
yeah also that
the chip is tucked away inside kompecki
plaza the hotel
you ever been
[Music]
[Laughter]
i remember what we're wearing
oh guns floating around a little bit
oh no i have to load again out of that
[Music]
[Applause]
there it is that was it i didn't have to
do the whole
investigating thing or no maybe i go
back in
i think i go back in all right get ready
for another loading screen
[Applause]
i'll sever the link to the bd roller
sensory array
yep i have seen enough get ready for
another loading screen we're gonna have
to do
at least two more after this give me it
get me out of here judy please
all right oh loading it again
just gonna scan everything quickly and
get out of here
there we go
get everything you need me out of here
let us go
keep it i'll put it on ev's tab man
judy judy's got some style dude i love
you
yeah she's she's just like a really good
character all around well designed well
written
let me hear what you squared away either
you
father
so into the board beast then you zoom in
and it mutes them i guess so
either you father
wait what let's go see these bastards
all right
let's knock on their door go around
hello
i'll let you know later you're gonna
respond
no they're here
[Laughter]
yeah oh you did it
okay all right he's done we gotta get
the like double jump
cyber legs or whatever run
let's go home whoa he's pretty
he was just pent up he's got all this
energy from just
being so still
oh i survived no i didn't i think you're
anything but a coward
i know oh
is this it he's stuck in the box
oh that was a good one dude
all right here we go i think we can beat
the boss with our fists
yeah he's got heelys too
oh boy
be careful you i mean you're probably
fine i was about to say oh [ __ ]
it's been a while since i'm safe i feel
like oh [ __ ]
we're trading blows you know we're fine
it is funny isn't it the hell is going
on
oh come on
i'm determined to beat this guy with my
fist punching metal
oh yeah
easy did we kill him
i can't punch him dead
what
what what's going on huh
is he alive i don't know i want no part
of this
but if you got the cojones and you know
how to use them
yeah yeah yeah
unless you
[Laughter]
yeah random jackie this is us
my lift is here bye
all right that's gonna do it for this
episode episode three
uh jake it sounds like we have a big
heist the big heist mission after this
so uh yeah if you guys are watching and
you like what you see
and you want more give us a good old
like and sub
it really helps us out to keep making
more content like this
thank you jake see y'all next time see
y'all next time
[Music]
bye
[Music]
you